okay so methemoglobinemia
another qualitative hemoglobinopathies
so what is it
well methemoglobinemia is a blood
disorder in which the concentration of
met him aglow be over the percentage of
it in red blood cells is too high and
that's basically when it's greater than
1% it's considered too high so what's my
hemoglobin what is this stuff well if
you recall I mentioned it earlier in the
in the series when I talked about iron
three-plus so met hemoglobin or met HP
is hemoglobin with the oxidized form of
iron in place of the reduced form so if
there's Fe three-plus which like I said
the oxidized form in place of Fe 2 plus
and heme that's that hemoglobin is
called met hemoglobin and that's
important because that cannot bind
oxygen okay and met hemoglobin
hemoglobin emia is marked by a decrease
in the percent of owed to saturation
because of this many mclubbe and not
being able to bind oxygen but that
doesn't change the partial pressure of
oxygen okay now when it comes to measure
global anemia but that kind of came out
kind of fine
there's hereditary methemoglobinemia
which is also congenital
methemoglobinemia there's also acquired
or a cube mat hemoglobin emia okay when
it comes to the hereditary
methemoglobinemia it results from any
mutation that resulted in the
stabilization of met HB okay so anything
that stabilizes that oxidized form any
mutation that results in a stabilization
of that that oxidized form and heme
causes the hereditary form and it is
autosomal dominant it's possibly due to
it can be done
excuse me it can be due to a deficiency
in nadh cytochrome B 5 reductase also
called NADH met hemoglobin reductase and
it's characterized by a slate gray
cyanosis that's present from birth and
that site very cyanosis basically refers
to like a grayish blue
a color to the skin I even tried to make
tech color right here I don't know if
that's really that good but it's as
close as I can get better off googling
the color slight gray but otherwise when
it comes to hereditary or congenital
megalomania it's otherwise symptomatic
apart from the display grey sinuses okay
you